à la vie à la mort
[Musique]
ces quatre proches chevalier
s'affrontent pour s'attirer les grâces
de la couronne devant un public
surchauffé un spectacle joué et
travaillé dans les moindres détails
seigneur ce n'est rien de plus et
toujours à l'âge on doit y penser mon
mieux leur accord et se mettre dans la
peau d'un chevalier du moyen âge
d'accord comme comme on pensait acquise
qui se faisaient les tournois qu'on
commence à se battre et on doit faire
beaucoup de répétitions pour que ce soir
très réaliste un peu plus loin dans la
cité
morgane le forgeron safer il doit
préparer couteaux et fourchettes pour la
cour pour faire chauffer l'acier on
avait une forge donc à l'ancienne avec
un soufflet convenait activé pour
pouvoir faire chauffer rougir tout
simplement le charbon et faire chauffer
l'acier après à partir de là bas il
suffisait juste de taper sur son enclume
le morceau d'acier pour pouvoir créer
soit des couteaux soit des fourchettes
avec la foire aux laines c'est toute la
ville qui revient 800 ans en arrière
thatcher de feu ménestrel
prédicateur tous défilent dans les rues
de châteaudun dans des costumes plus
vrai que nature
je viens là tous les ans depuis de
nombreuses années et puis on apprécie va
la voir les chances donné du mal pour
organiser ça c'est génial c'est bien de
tous les gens nous applaudissent
[Musique]
trente mille visiteurs sont attendus
jusqu'à dimanche soir avant que
châteaudun reviennent peu à peu au 21ème
siècle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]